she composed for the legendary Aretha
Franklin
Beyonce called her one of the best
rappers ever
and outcasts even opened for her we're
talking about no one other than Ms
Lauren Hill her Talent is undeniable
Rolling Stone named her one of the
greatest singers of all Time and Time
Magazine up to the queen of hip-hop but
she only released one studio album so
how did she accomplish so much this is
Miss Lauren Hill's story and how she
became one of the most celebrated
influential and respected artists in
music history
[Music]
first let's go way back to before she
became a music icon and a household name
in 1987 L boogie performed at the famous
live show amateur night at the Apollo
and was booed
but as she continued to sing the crowd
eventually came around and clapped for
her in the end not knowing that they
just witnessed the beginning of History
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you
three years later miss Hill would make
another public appearance as a
background dancer in the music video for
poor Georgie by MC Lyte but she wouldn't
stay in the background for long picture
it the scene is Columbia High School in
Maplewood New Jersey
Michelle known as Pras approaches Miss
Hill about joining the group he would
later introduce her to Wyclef Jean and
together they became known as the Fugees
as they worked on their debut album Ms
Hill continued her acting career which
led to her getting cast as Rita Louise
Watson in Sister Act 2 alongside Whoopi
Goldberg
the film served as a breakout film from
his Hill who also contributed to the
soundtrack
in 1994 the Fuji's dropped their first
album
said the album concoction Brash smart
rafts drawing on Jamaican dancehall
rhythms as well as American hip-hop and
Miss hill was a standout she showed the
ability to switch between being a
hard-hitting rapper like Ice Cube
to being effortlessly Jazzy with her
delivery
we flee our own community
's we leave our family in poverty
but it wasn't until their sophomore
album the score was released that the
Fugees reached new levels of success in
the score they found their own unique
voice cros and Wycliffe lean more into
the Caribbean Heritage Fuji's is short
for refugees after all and Miss healed
brought more of her bluesy inspiration
El Boogie's Soulful Talent is all full
display and they're chilling his single
ready or not
[Music]
Miss Hill laser heart bear with
emotional vocals and even cried while
recording before delivering one of her
most popular lines
but it was Miss Hill's cover of Killing
Me Softly with his song that ended up
being the most popular single from the
album in the middle of the hard-hitting
15 track rap album Miss Hill brought new
life to the 70s song with a sample from
A Tribe Called Quest the song's hip-hop
production matched with Miss Hills raspy
at smooth voice and made the song an
instant classic just listen to this run
foreign
the score went on to win the Grammy
award for best rap album making Miss
Hill the first woman to win a Grammy in
that category
a love triangle and creative and
financial disagreements made it hard for
the fujis to continue forward as a group
after Miss Hill and Wyclef Jean ended
their tumultuous relationship the Fuji's
broke up and Miss Hill went solo
an early 20-something-year-old Miss Hill
started crafting the early parts of an
album in her living room in her hometown
South Orange New Jersey her label
reportedly wanted her to release another
album with the Fugees but miss Hill
forged ahead by recruiting her own team
to help her achieve her vision
she told Rolling Stone I wanted to write
songs that lyrically moved me and have
the Integrity of Reggae and the knock of
hip-hop and the instrumentation of
classic soul
between label pressure to wrap up the
album naysayers filming the movie
restaurant and giving birth to her son
Zaya she got it done for her debut solo
album The miseducation of Lauren Hill
she Drew from her personal experience to
create a raw emotional cross genre album
that explored themes of love black
empowerment social justice femininity
motherhood and more She lays out all of
her emotions on the album in the Soulful
ballad X Factor she Mourns her
relationship with Wyclef Jean
[Music]
in X Factor although she's singing her
voice bounces on top of the beat in a
way that embodies a rap flow
[Music]
this sound would also help pave the way
for Neo-Soul music alongside the
Artistry of Erica Badu floatree and Jill
Scott you can hear Miss Hill's motown's
Soul influence in songs like doo-wop
that thing
baby girl
[Music]
the track's hook and riff samples the
Soul band The Fifth Dimension
duop Miss Hill also showcases her
lyrical Flair proving why miseducation
is seen as one of the best rap albums
[Music]
album is also influenced by Jamaican
dancehall as well as the sounds and
philosophy of Reggae half of the album
is recorded at Bob Marley studio in
Jamaica and at the time she was in a
relationship with Marley's son Rohan in
the track lost Ones Miss Hill's vocals
call back to Sister Nancy's hit dance
hall record bomb bomb it's all done
[Music]
to learn more about the influence of the
miseducation I sat down with Nadira
founder of the gumbo a magazine that
celebrates black women in hip-hop I
think one thing that we don't talk about
a lot though or at least I love to talk
about
um is the blues and we know it's the
influence of blues artists in her music
and I think if you're hearing the call
and response and Old Blue songs and
you're hearing Lauren sing and you're
hearing them respond with chance and
stuff like that and and shouting
especially on songs like to Zion it's
just so prevalent and it's so obvious
there
[Music]
oh my
when it comes to women in blues and how
they were using if you think about
Maureen you think about Bessie Smith
they were using the blues to talk about
you know love and relationships and
family and heartbreak and all these
different things that weren't really
being done in that way in music and I
think that's what makes it such a great
body of work is that she is taking all
of these things and taking all these
influences and really making them her
own and just nodding to all these
different parts of of the music that we
have
now let's talk stats the album which is
her only solo album to date will become
one of the most highly acclaimed albums
of all time with over 20 million copies
sold worldwide it debuted at the number
one spot on Billboard 200 chart breaking
Madonna's record for first week sales by
a female artist during that time she was
also a musical guest on Saturday Night
Live and had a sold out World Tour and
let's not forget about her 10 Grammy
nominations in five wins including album
of the year making her the first rapper
to win album of the Year Ms Neil's
Talent earned her the respect from her
predecessors and peers
in an interview with billboard Grammy
nominated rapper Rhapsody said she knew
how to incorporate Melody into a rhyme
so people could sing along with her even
as she was rapping about things that
might have been complex in the same
interview lizzo noted that she set the
bar I was always afraid of being a
singer but then when I heard Lauren Hill
I was like maybe I can do both
even though the miseducation of Lauryn
Hill was such a great success the world
is still waiting on a sophomore album
over 20 years later Museo said that lack
of support and ideological differences
were the reasons that it never happened
in an interview with rolling stone Miss
Hill said no one from my label has ever
called me and asked how can we help you
make another album ever
with a miseducation there was no
precedent I was for the most part free
to explore experiment and express after
the miseducation there were scores of
tentacled obstructionists politics
repressing agendas unrealistic
expectations and saboteurs everywhere
with only one solo album some think Miss
Hill's Legacy stops with miseducation
but that's not true
in 2002 she released an MTV Unplugged
album which included a performance of
mystery of iniquity that was later
sampled on Kanye West's All Falls Down
[Music]
Miss Hill also wrote and produced songs
for Legends like Aretha Franklin Mary J
Blige CeCe Winans Whitney Houston and
Santana why do you think Miss Lauren
Hill has only released one album
everyone talks about this so much also I
couldn't imagine creating something like
the miseducation of Lauren Hill Lauren
Hill and then
trying to follow it up with all that
pressure on me because one I gave y'all
something really good I also did the
live album I haven't completely like
disappeared or whatever but I'm also a
human being
[Music]
Miss Hill continues to tour and performs
new Renditions of her songs to keep it
fresh for her audiences and herself
since the Fugees broke up in 1997 they
performed together a few times and
there's been talk of another reunion and
while she draws criticism for only
releasing one studio album her influence
can be heard in the music of today's
chart Toppers like Beyonce Adele J Cole
Drake and cardi B
[Music]
I feel like a lot of the young artists
especially because I'm an r b especially
in r b
like take a lot of Lauren influence they
definitely do they definitely do and
even I feel like a lot of the women who
rap now too if you ask them you know who
are your favorite they almost off the
all the time they say Lauryn Hill and
I'm just like this is a testament to her
impact good night you guys thank you
very much thank you for your patience
before you go I want to let you know
about fight the power how hip-hop
changed the world a new PBS series
hosted by hip-hop Legend Chuck D it's
about how hip-hop became a global
movement that spoke truth to power check
out the link in the description below
and let them know soundfield sent you
foreign